We are bringing another girl
on to the brokerage.
-Really?
-Yeah. Chrishell.
Chrishell, okay.
I really put a lot of focus
on my career.
So now I definitely
would say
I'm one of
the top selling agents
at the Oppenheim Group
and I worked really hard
and I'm finally in a place
to buy my own house.
So it's definitely
looking up.
Oh my god.
It's all ready for you
to decorate, Amanza.
What do you guys think?
I love it.
I am so happy for you.
-Hi. You're welcome.
-Hi.
-Hi, how are you? Good.
-I'm good. How are you?
You're welcome.
Oh, you're so cute.
Hi, cutie.
Can I give this to you?
Thank you.
Here you go.
I think there's
a huge stigma
with growing up
in poverty or,
you know, being homeless.
I mean, I think these
charities are important.
Because
when you treat people
in a bad situation
with respect,
that's when they
really feel uplifted
and maybe they can garner
some change in their life.
It's a moving thing
to be a part of.
-Thank you guys.
-It's awesome.
It was honestly so nice,
being here and you know,
just smile to people
and make eye contact
and give them--
That's what like, for me,
like our family was one of
the families in that line.
So it's been like
so gratifying to be here,
but also like,
it's hard to like--
-A little emotional?
-A little emotional.
Just because it's like,
when you see that boy.
It's like I remember
being in that line so,
I'm so happy
that you guys did this.
I'm sorry,
I'm such a mess today.
I feel like, at that dinner
you conveniently--
This isn't about making
points right now.
Can you stop.
I'm trying to make--
I know, but you made
your point. Trust me.
Can I reiterate
and you get off my back?
I always own up to my stuff.
If, in the moment,
I didn't know exactly
what she was talking about.
Now,
I've already talked to Mary.
I've told her
everything I said.
I own up
to everything I said.
I understand that.
But we came back from
the bathroom Maya and I
and we had asked you what
you guys were talking about
and you said
"I don't remember.
I just said stuff about
Mary and Romain."
Christine, I'm not gonna
have this conversation.
Because you know
that I'm right.
Christine, here's the thing.
You said you don't remember.
It makes you sound
like you're two-faced.
Also, I don't have to
tell you what I said.
Also, it makes you sound
like you're two-faced
when you don't own up
to the shit that you say.
Do you understand
where I'm coming from?
When I ask you
what did you say.
-When I ask you--
-Don't yell at me.
-what did you say.
-Okay, hold on.
And you don't own up
to what you said,
it makes you look like
a crazy person.
If you keep yelling at me
I'm not gonna listen to you.
I always own up
to what I say.
I say "Yeah,
I've said this, so what?
Yeah, I've said it,
I'll back it up."
I've talked to Mary
about what I've said.
But when I asked you
at the dinner,
you conveniently
didn't remember.
You understand the
difference, right.
Or do you
still have dementia?
Christine.
Leave everything behind.
I mean come one. Yeah, no
rebuttal because I'm right.
Christine, this is enough.
-I'm leaving.
-Seriously?
Don't do this again to me.
We had a fight that morning
over the phone
and I never saw him since.
We didn't talk
things through and…
before we had a chance
to figure anything out
he'd filed.
How did you find out?
Did he like just
come talk to you
out of the blue or what?
I found out
because he texted me…
that we were filed.
He texted you?
45 minutes later
the world knew.
He just blind sighted you?
Because of the crazy way
in which this went down,
people want answers.
And I fucking want answers.
That's shitty.
Like beyond shitty.
I know people
are saying like,
we were only married
two years, but it's like,
we were together
for six years.
You deserve
more respect than that.
I'm good
not being friends with you.
It's been a very toxic
relationship
having you in my life
and so many times
you've brought
toxic energy to me.
And so I don't want anything
to do with that.
Are you saying that you
will not give me a chance
to be your friend?
It looks like
it's going well.
One of them
is gonna finish in the pool.
No, I think actually--
-I have a good feeling.
-I've seen some laughing.
It's been a bit--
Every time I deal with you,
you do something insanely,
ridiculously hurtful
like telling all the girls
not to like my Instagram's.
Like, when you had a party
and you made fun of me
on the drink list
to 100's of your guests.
She named a drink
"The Two-Face Chrishell."
Okay,
you know what actually,
it's "Chrishell's
Two Faced Tonic."
I'm sorry.
You know I actually do have
two faces for her
I have to say,
because I don't like her
so I'm trying
to be professional and,
so this is probably
the face that I give her.
Do I look dead
behind the eyes?
Because
you had a party prior
and didn't invite me.
I didn't have a party prior.
You had a party prior
and you didn't invite me.
Christine, we had parties
on the same night.
But I didn't put your face
on a drink list
and made fun
of you to all of my guests.
To me in saying
that you could do
all of this crazy behaviour
and then sit here and
act like nothing happened.
This is my olive branch.
I've reached out many times.
I do appreciate the apology.
It's more
than I was expecting.
What do they say,
keep your friends close,
keep your enemies closer?
Hey baby, how's it going?
That's never been truer
than with Christine.